here we are behind the scenes with
loki there's no denying the magnetic
appeal of
loki tom hiddleston's incredible
performance gets most of the credit
but even he needs help bringing the
trickster god to life on film
to celebrate loki getting his very own
series we're giving you a look at some
behind-the-scenes magic of how marvel
brings the god of mischief to the screen
in all his glory loki is still working
on that i think
for this scene from thor the dark world
the first thing they filmed was tom
hiddleston doing an impression of
captain america as loki
complete with cap's costume there wasn't
a technical reason for this
apparently tom just really wanted to
wear the costume
it's not going to be you though we're
going to get chris to shoot it when he's
on set and we're gonna
he said no no this is my one chance to
wear captain america suits
later evans was shown the footage and
did his best to mimic tom's performance
replacing it in the final product he
it's him doing an impression of me
doing an impression of him and it's
brilliant
a good villain needs a grand entrance
and loki certainly doesn't disappoint
loki's entrance in the first avengers
movie is a memorable one
thanks in no small part to the vfx team
even without the final polish and the
wires still in sight
this shot of tom performing this stunt
is just as impressive as the finished
shot from the movie
where loki leaps through the air and
takes down a shield agent
always try and enjoy myself to be having
the best time
speaking of dramatic entrances this
scene from the first episode of loki
where he's being processed by the tva
was achieved with a real trapdoor and
tom hiddleston on wires
he was hooked up to a rig to achieve a
controlled drop ensuring his safety as
they filmed the stunt
luckily tom already has a lot of
experience doing wire work since
loki always seems to be getting tossed
around just me
jumping into trenches in the set
creating that iconic scene where loki
gets hulk smashed was
tricky you can't exactly do that with
stunt work to pull this off tom had a
wire attached to his ankle with a mat on
the floor to catch him
and three of the strongest stunt guys
holding
the wire at the other end they waited to
interrupt his villainous monologue and
yanked
hard pulling tom out of frame and down
onto the mat
the rest was done with hard work from
the special effects department
the experience of being yanked out of
frame was one i will not forget in a
hurry
loki and thor's banter in this scene
from thor the dark world where they
break out of asgard is unforgettable as
well as a brilliant mix of practical and
special effects
chris and tom filmed this scene on a set
of the ship's interior
with special effects creating the
holographic interfaces and adjusting the
lighting accordingly
while thor practically throws loki out
the door chris gives tom
a light shove who then has to throw
himself out of the door
onto a mat below i mentioned i love my
scenes with chris
in every film there's a two-hander where
we kind of touch on this
odin's emotional departure in thor
ragnarok took place on a beautiful
scenic cliffside that doesn't actually
exist
these scenes were filmed in a grassy
field with the future locations of new
asgard being entirely built around them
using cgi
another surprising use of digital
effects in this scene is odin's eye
patch
which was changed in post from the plain
black eye patch anthony hopkins
wore while filming yeah that easy well
it's a trick
dramatic entrances probably run in the
family because as soon as hella arrives
on the scene
you know she means business thor and
loki immediately know she's going to be
trouble and suit up
to get this magical costume change chris
and tom were filmed entering in both
costumes
the footage was spliced together and the
effects team created thor's lightning
and loki's signature green shimmer of
magic
to create a transition between these
changes putting them together for one
seamless shot
look he was a bad guy well lucky was a
misunderstood guy
we love seeing the odin sons work
together like when they teamed up in the
dark world
using loki's illusion magic they fooled
malekith into believing loki had
betrayed thor
going as far as pretending to cut off
thor's hand and give up jane foster
it's very accurate in this shot loki
literally kicks thor while he's down
sending him rolling on set it was
hiddleston
delivering a kick that didn't connect
and hemsworth was pulled away using
wires
never was torturous at all so i'm
incredibly proud of this
while there were parts of thor and
loki's confrontation with malikith that
were filmed on location in iceland
taking advantage of some barren volcanic
landscapes the more effects heavy shots
were filmed on a green screen
set this behind the scenes footage
really gives you an appreciation for the
amount of faith actors have to put into
their directors and their special
effects team
there's an art to the physicality of
performances with invisible elements
like cgi magic and tom pulls it off
beautifully while it may look silly on
set the final product was anything but
it can be surprising exactly which
elements of a scene are created using
cgi
like loki's chains in the avengers yeah
for whatever reason those were cgi
not part of tom's costume like they were
for thor the dark world
loki's restraints and muzzle add a lot
of context to these shots so the behind
the scenes footage of the closing scene
looks pretty different without them
props to tom for being able to
convincingly move like someone in chains
even limiting how much he moved his
mouth and jaw
i think well there was always going to
be an unanswered question of what on
earth happened
getting hulk smashed became an odinson
tradition in thor ragnarok when thor
faced off against hulk in the arena
loki clearly still holding on to some
baggage from his fight with hulk
is thrilled to see thor get the same
treatment of course
tom didn't actually have a spectacular
fight to react to
you would never guess that the only
thing he's really looking at is a room
full of cameras and crew
in the first avengers movie thanos uses
one of his followers referred to as the
other to keep an eye on loki and monitor
his progress
conquering earth the final cut only kept
one of their conversations in
with some horrific implications that
loki was being threatened with torture
but there were several more exchanges
between the two that got left out
these deleted scenes are unfinished but
give us an idea of what the raw filming
process looked like
while the other himself was achieved
with practical effects played by alexis
denisov in sculpts and makeup the alien
world he hangs out in when speaking to
loki was mostly blue screen
they followed me into some interesting
corners in the first thor movie we meet
the frost giants
and later learned that loki was
originally the son of their king
not odin most of the frost giants or
yotens as they're also called were
filmed using practical effects
the actors would spend hours having
sculpts and makeup applied to them to
achieve
just the right look but this lengthy
process wouldn't have been practical for
tom's brief scenes in loki's yotan skin
instead his red eyes and blue skin were
added in post
as soon as i look in the mirror after
i've been through it's like wow
ever wonder why loki's helmet has
changed so many times since the first
thor movie
even putting on the helmet was more
complicated than you think
since tom couldn't just pull it on over
his head the final product used in thor
actually had to come apart in two pieces
which would be snapped together to
encase tom's head
according to him it was like having his
brain cooked all of his body heat would
build up under the helmet
driving him a bit mad which he says he
used to fuel his performance
that's probably why we see a lot less of
it in the avengers and it didn't return
until
thor ragnarok with a more minimalist
redesign
you have to be careful what you're
letting in because you can
that can sort of spill into what you're
doing last but not least is this deleted
scene from
thor it's a fun character moment where
loki gets to cause some mischief
after being mocked and laughed at loki
gets even by turning a goblet of wine
into snakes
the effects are unfinished and there's
even some shots where lighting rigs are
still visible
props to this extra who had to
convincingly react to a magical prank
that wasn't
actually happening did you know tom
originally auditioned for the role of
thor
they said his look wasn't quite right
for the role but when they saw him they
knew
almost immediately they needed him to
play loki from the massive popularity
his character has achieved it's easy to
see they made the right call